Hello everyone, welcome back to another episode of the Grand Prixquel Podcast where we discuss
all things feeder series. On today's episode we are going to be doing a recap of the F2 and
F3 weekends at the Red Bull Ring, as well as doing a preview of the upcoming E4 Championship.
Our hosts for today are myself, Robin, Alex, Nova and Peter.
Yeah, so starting with Formula 2 looking to qualifying. I mean, I think we should look
towards who is going to be on the sprint front row. Here we had Montoya in 10th and Bennett in
P9, making them our front row for the sprint race. I'm sorry, what?
But I just want to point out in general that I think this weekend kind of, I think Red Bull
Ring is a great place and one of those tracks where you can really see the strengths of teams
and I think it's really interesting to see that such a, more typical track seems to be
fitting for Bennett. I mean, the whole quali session was a bit weird with
Noel Leon already doing his lap fairly early on and then just being fine with it.
Kind of, you know, boss move, if you ask me. I feel like it tells a lot about strengths of
different drivers and different teams because y'all have to correct me, but I swear that
Varrone and Herta were down pretty low, and for both of them it's a track that they have not
driven or not driven in quite a long time, and I think it's really telling how
you can see the strengths of drivers coming with this experience and on the other end also
the teams that I'm a bit surprised about because I did expect Invicta to be the clear strongest
again, because I swear that in the last years tracks, like this was really fast paced and you need to
be really quick and also the strategy to get them on track in the right moment, has always been
their strong suit. I mean, last year Leonardo Fornaroli had his pole position here because
back then, I swear we’ve all said, this track can really fit the Invicta crew like the way they operated.
Yeah, I think it's also- I feel like there's not really a clear top team in terms of pace like
there maybe was last year. Like last time out Invicta were really strong at Spain,
especially with how good they are on the tyres whereas over here it wasn't so strong, but I mean
Camara is still consistently getting those points, which is the main thing in F2 is consistency.
So guess we’ll maybe have to wait and see because we still have a fair few number of rounds to go.
Yeah, but I feel like it's very clear that, the German commentary also mentioned that,
Campos in quite a lot of series made clear steps forward during the winter break and they seem
to be really really up there and really fighting for being the quickest
car, you know? In every series but Eurocup-3, they've somehow regressed in the one series
I care about. I think that’s just the Alex Powell curse and of course you’re here to bring him up
in an episode where he's not even meant to be mentioned. Whatever. I have a feeling this is not the first
Campos pole but apparently it is. I did not think that. I feel like both the drivers have been
so strong and so quick. I think like Tsolov is always somewhere in the top five so he's-
or top 10. He's always starting somewhere around there. Was he not on pole in Monaco?
No, Camara took pole in Monaco, I'm pretty sure. Oh yeah, and then oh- I remember then he like
fluffed it he went off into the-. Camara took it at the very end of qualifying.
Yeah of course sorry, my mistake. Anyways, I think moving on to the sprint race. I mean I
think the main thing, I'm just still surprised at how well Bennett has been doing I think-
He played a really smart race. He got the initial lead then, yeah he lost the lead but he still
kept pace with Montoya and kind of, he attacked. Last lap moves as always- I mean kind of aura farming
with that but it's still pretty cool. And yeah I mean, hopefully we begin to see more of Bennett
you know, because having a win, albeit in a sprint, is still going to be a massive boost of confidence
for any driver. I mean interestingly enough, Trident has been the better team than Prema
so far this season and I think Bennett is a driver that should be able to do it. His career has just
been so incredibly weird. Yeah, and towards the end it was also interesting how quickly Montoya
fell away cause Villagomez was suddenly all over the back of him as well. Like one more lap
and he'd have been overtaken by Villagomez, I reckon, because he's literally all over the back
of him throughout that final third sector where, you can't really overtake in that third sector
that's why I think Villagomez didn't get past but. I mean I assume for a lot of drivers especially
when in the top, we saw the Red Bull Ring is not the easiest on the tyres. I think I could imagine
if you played the tyre game the right way and if you also took the DRS which is fairly good around
here I think that's a really good way to be up there, and I feel like we saw that with drivers
like Villagomez really work out. It felt almost like an F3 race in the way they were all having to
keep their tyres alive and that came really important towards the end. But I think generally
it was a fairly comparably uneventful race like…oh no, it was not like- the first lap was a bit
chaotic you know, when there was a lot of incidents. I felt like it was weird because it was a lot of
smaller incidents but it all bundled up into one bigger incident. I mean we never really got a
proper replay of that cause the camera was really far away, you couldn't see s***. Now the
problem was rather for me that there was so much happening simultaneously that it's really hard
to also judge who's at fault for what, because you have in the first lap obviously a lot of cars
going side by side through the corners, and at some point I think it was Camara who hit someone
in the back, I don't remember who the person spun around, took Tsolov with them, for some reason one of
the AIX cars was also involved, had to almost stop, there's just a lot of drama and I think
that's kind of really typical for F2 but it's generally the only thing from that weekend
not from that weekend, from that race, that I remember as being really typically F2 fashion, the rest of it
was pretty, you know, tame for F2. Yeah, also speaking of Tsolov, he made a good recovery
of that incident because it was impressive I mean he- I've said this quite a few times on the
podcast now, but he continues to impress me with what he's doing, cause yes the Red Bull Ring is
relatively easier to overtake on compared to other tracks, especially
with those DRS zones at the start, but he's also just making those moves when he needs to and he's
kept the cars alive. And yeah, it was a shame also to see Colton Herta to get Mechachromed, because
he was when we were on the top 10 when it happened and I was hoping, maybe he's keeping his
tires alive, maybe we can see a few more points from him, but the engine just kind of gave up on
him. I'm really disappointed in Hitech this season because at the very least in 2024, they were
one of those really strong teams and I expected a lot more from there. Even last year they like- Luke
won last year I think with them. I don’t remember, I just remember when Paul Aron was with the team and
we said a lot because we, we all said that, who was it? Amaury Cordeel, I think, was really underperforming
when the car would have been a lot better and I feel like it's the entire way around now where we
have two really great drivers who could perform, and I think are performing to the best of what they
can currently do with their experience and the things that they do, but there's just so many
issues, so many small issues or so many things that just don't go
right, and it could be the fact that Hitech has had some weird stuff going on in the background
but like. I'm a bit disappointed. I think beyond that, I don't have too much more to say about the
sprint race. I think it was a solid race just typically F2, bit of chaos I mean
we had quite the surprising podium I feel like because you don't always see a podium
including like drivers who are doing their first podiums of their whole F2 career, or if the whole
season. Pretty sure all of them had their first podium for the season here. Wait, no,
Villagomez at least has had podiums before in F2, but for the season
I think it's even his first points. And somehow even after that sprint podium he’s still last
in the standings. Oh. What do we got now? Uh, the feature race. Yeah I mean, uh Tsolov again going
for the win but. I mean the battle between Tsolov, Dunne and Mini and I mean again, Tsolov and Dunne
racing each other cleanly. Have they changed? They did this last week, they did last time out
in Spain, they’re doing it again. They're both reformed people, almost it’s as if. I'm really glad because I
think we're lining up for an incredible title fight and what we saw in that feature, I think
was a great race, because we were really lucky to have quite a lot of drivers fighting for the lead,
drivers whose lead also means a lot for the championship and the things and the points
that they're scoring. Like, we have once again Gabriele Mini, who finished P2 and continues his very, very
solid streak of podiums, and we talked about it earlier, I don't remember what, but it's really
important in F2 to consistently score points and so far, he has scored points in every single race
but one and he's had, I think seven podiums in 12 races like that's a really, really good
statistic. And I think a lot of drivers will say they want to win obviously, but there is reason why
he's currently above Tsolov in the standings, even though Tsolov has three more wins than him, because
you know Tsolov either has like win or there is uh oftentimes also more retirements, also more
incidents that send him to the back of the pack so. I think we're lining up to see a really
interesting battle up there, and I think as you’ve mentioned it's great to see the way that they
drove all cleanly, and even though they were fighting quite a lot also with just the whole
group of Mini, Tsolov, Camara and Dunne, no one of them DNF'd, I think there was a really strong
result and really strong showing for them. So I mean, Dunne's end of the race was interesting to say
the least. I mean not to- maybe he had some clutch issues or something but. I assumed he just cooked
his tires because like there was a lot of, a lot of fights, and I could really imagine that stuff
really going on your tires after a while. I mean, he had clutch issues at the start I believe and-
but also he did run wide at the start of the finish straight going off track so that maybe
caused some minor damage as well. Like I said, I mean, look at the championship it is, I mean, Tsolov and
Mini are only separated by two points. Incredibly close up there. And even the likes of Camara and
Dunne aren't too further back, with Camara being 24 points behind Tsolov and Dunne only two points
behind Tsolov- I mean behind Camara. I mean we still have quite a few races, I think we're at
almost half the season and I think what we've seen also you can- I mean look at Tsolov’s stats you can
win two races and then do not score points in the next four races. He’s actually won three feature
races. Yeah but I was looking at the Australia feature and Miami sprint which won and then
did not score points for four races and then he won again. The fact he’s won three feature races
that's 75- pretty much 75 percent of his points have come from that. But also I think it's really interesting
then to think about what Campos is doing, what Campos is clearly doing right that they seem to
always put them on the correct strategy for the win and that they clearly have the pace to do it.
Even Leon is there in P5 in the championship.
I feel like he's one of those drivers where we don't really– I mean I think he's a solid driver
but I think if we compare him to other drivers who have relationships to F1 teams who are below
him like Dino Beganovic or Kush Maini or even Colton Herta, I think no one really expected him
to be that up far but considering the team and car, he really should be. I mean, Campos have
become underrated, like last year they also performed well. I mean, 2024 with Hadjar, they were good in the title
fight; last year, they had Arvid Lindblad. They’ve always been kinda up there, but as you said they've
taken a step further almost. I feel like what they're doing right now, I have not seen them
do a mistake. Like, I feel like in 2024 we complained quite a lot about, especially
strategy mistakes that they've made, and just like little things that didn't line up. Last year,
it was the same and I feel like this year, it just really kind of all falls together and we seem to
have done the best. But I think even though it was a good race, I think it was besides the battle
between the leaders of the championship, it was actually surprisingly little going on, except for
the fact when Boya suddenly went up into flames. That was a real Formula 2 moment. That's always got to
happen at some point we've got to have someone be Mecachromed in every race so. It was really impressive
that Herta didn't like just crash straight into the back of him. I could not be a racing driver
because that would stress me out. I would just panic and crash. What if my car turned fire next?
Mini in the cool down room after he like, went past Boya, he was so funny and I feel like
he's spiritually what I am on the podcast. Just dramatic yapping constantly. It was, it was great.
Overall I'm really grateful that the way it seems right now, there's really no
favorite for the championship title. Like last year, we knew that the Invicta was the strongest
car and so we all hoped others could also be in a title fight, but for me it was pretty clear that
it was not likely to happen, but at the moment, I'm going to be honest, I don't think MP is the
strongest car; and I feel like they've made quite a few mistakes, especially with Ollie Goethe which I
know a lot of others we know are kind of mad about, and Gabriele Mini, he's doing a good season
but how do you do that against two drivers who are considered to be in better cars with
Tsolov and Camara right behind him. And, Alex Dunne is, I think the one who was, from the bunch of them,
the highest in the championship last season, so it's a really interesting class and it's lining
up to be a lot more interesting than I thought it would be, which is great. Yeah, and of course
as we've alluded to in the team championship. surprise, surprise! Campos is first. Who would have
expected that? Unless anyone has anything more to say about F2, I think we’ll move on to F3 now.
We can move on to F3. Before we get into any of the racing, we have a new driver for the– we had a
new driver for the AIX seat: Salim Hanna was in; and I thought it was really funny because I was expecting
KNB, like if they were to pick any of the three FREC drivers, I thought it was going to be KNB,
but it wasn't. And especially it’d have been funny to have him after his last time out at the Red Bull
Ring, that was quite eventful– sorry, Nova but, that was quite, it was quite eventful to say the least.
It was, but Salim was a surprise, honestly. I think out of all the drivers that were put forward as a
possible like, filler I wasn't expecting Salim at all. It's just I guess whoever can pay. Yeah.
And luckily for us, we are recording on a Wednesday, which means we already know who is in
for Silverstone. We don't need to wait and say ‘Oh my god, have they announced it after the episode?’
We know. Um, they're bringing Escotto back. Who knows, they've just announced actually someone else.
I guess there's so many other series happening this week with, of course, there's E4 happening,
there's FREC going on, EC3 is racing, I think GB3 is as well. The thing is, IndyNXT is on too.
But I guess, is there any series which was not racing this week where a driver could realistically
step up to F3? Super Formula Lights. Evan Giltaire. Bring Evan Giltaire into F3. I really would have
liked to see either Giltaire or Bohra show up but um, it's Escotto again. Don't know why he's
prioritizing an F3 cameo over his IndyNXT season but whatever. And Salim, he's actually
done a solid job in qualifying because he's the highest AIX so I mean, good job. I mean the other two AIX drivers
are… yeah, but still a good achievement to have, I think. That sounds so mean, oh my god. I feel
like- Wait, I need to, I need to look up who the AIX drivers actually are. It's Yevan David and
Fernando Barichello. That's both drivers who do not have a lot of experience, especially like
it's their first season in F3 and, I mean, I'm pretty sure Brad Benavides also would
outqualify them pretty clearly. Yeah, and also I guess Salim, he's been to the track before which helps.
He’s of course, was here for FREC. Yeah, but at the same time, it's, he's a rookie in FREC and last year
was his F4 rookie season as well. So he's- yeah, he's still done quite a good job I think, it's not like
we don't want to take away from that. Considering he's in an AIX, I was a bit impressed, yeah. And
I mean it's quite surprising because Nael, where was Nael? He's been like, he's been so good in
qualifying and then he's been kind of ghosted, to say the least. Nael and Badoer were both
nowhere. He was only P25 in qualifying, Nael and that was a real surprise cause. Yeah I watched
qualifying, but what happened? Because I cannot imagine that he just did not have the speed.
I think it was probably track limits or something. Like just his laps kept getting deleted and so he
just didn't have any good ones. That's a good explanation and I'm going to accept that as being
the right one. Yeah, especially you know we've seen how strong Campos have been this year.
I mean we had Ugochukwu who was second, Rivera was also in the top 12. Maybe not as strong as they
were in Spain but they're still quite strong here. That's because Spain is their home track and they
know it the best. They will always be kind of the one to beat there because again it is their
home track. It's a track that they have a lot more when they race in, what Robin will know more
about, the Spanish serieses. Again, Alex Powell mention number two. I'm still annoyed that Campos has not
been dominating Eurocup-3, but that's a problem for another episode. I'm not going to-
And then within the sprint race. Rivera, I mean, the way he's come back from injury, has been
really impressive. Of course, he missed the first round because of a back injury. He's come back and he's
been really good and getting a win. He did really good, nice overtake on Wharton. I mean, he's P11
in the standings, even after missing a whole round; so I think that on one hand, that shows the way
that he's been really good at getting used to the cars with arguably, you know, a bit less time
than the others but also obviously he has a good car. He's in a good team. Also I want to talk about
what happened at the start. Maybe I don't want to talk about it. Stromsted took Slater out. Well
technically, it was a racing incident. Okay but, if you watch it, Stromsted just basically oversteered
into Freddie. Freddie gave him room. Kind of what should he have done? Because I mean, I'm pretty
sure that it was also a racing incident because it was the first lap. I just want to blame Stromsted.
I'm just going to blame him because he crashed into Freddie and took Freddie out of the race.
Of course. Yeah, you're biased and I think that's not cool. I think it's really important to keep
in mind that it was the first lap. There was a lot of stuff going on and when you have to decide
between you know, a lot of times they're saying “Hey, I can do this.” and only then, they oversteer
and they look then they realize “Oh sh*t, I can't do this. I actually, you know, overestimated myself.”
At that point, there's no way to take it back. If you go into any situation thinking “how could this
end badly” you'll make a really, really f*cking sh*t racing driver; because if that didn't happen,
he would have had a pretty good start, and if we go from in a hundred situations where it's the
same start, he would not have oversteered into– I don't care, he crashed into Freddie, that's all I.
Maybe Freddie should have just qualified on pole and not been in the way. Stop being biased
Peter. Why can't I be biased? Why can I not be biased? Because I'm against biases. Cause I’m evil.
Moving on, moving on. Clerot had some really good overtakes during the race. There was
one point where he overtook two cars into one corner. I don't remember whether that was the-
but it was really good. He's got a strong weekend overall and yeah. Wharton at the end–
his best one so far. Wharton at the end just fell off completely. He was there in P2 and he just lost
like- he just got swamped by. I could imagine that it is the tyres, yeah, potential tyre overheating,
you know, overdoing the tyres, and suddenly the guys behind you and they've been using the DRS
the whole time, they've been there, and they've not pushed as hard and suddenly you know, they're
dangerous. It was nice to see Nakamura on the podium, I liked that. Was that not the race where
we had like- no, Kanato Le was disqualified but if he was not disqualified, we would have had all four
Japanese drivers in the top 10 which I also found to be quite interesting. There's something about
Austria that the Japanese drivers really like, somehow. Or hate. KNB, there's something, he
doesn't like Austria. I mean, he's part Japanese. He's not Japanese enough. Maybe you need to be
fully Japanese. He hated it so much we made up a new verb for the Austria weekend
actually, I think. But yeah, so good performance from all the Japanese drivers this weekend.
There can only be one Nakamura in Austria and it's not Kean Nakamura-Berta. Oh my god, imagine
the confusion with the commentators if Jin and Kean both raced together in the same weekend.
Nakamura against Nakamura. I mean they did call Jin they called Jin Nakajima at some point in one
of the races so there's only one Nakamura and they're still messing up his name. You know what I just
saw, what I think is actually really hilarious? Brad Benavides only did two rounds out of the
four we've done so far and he's still P18 in the championship and there's so many guys below him.
That's so bad actually. He also only scored points, like, once. That's horrific. I think, someday we
need to have a conversation of if F3 the way it is right now actually makes sense because this is
just sad. Last thing I want to mention about the sprint race is that Enzo was having some kind of
mechanical issue at the start which is why he had like a horrific start; and then I don't know what
McLaughlin was doing but he went off track came back on track and just went straight into the
side of Enzo and his like- they were both fine I think. Wait, I don't remember what happened to
Fionn after that but Enzo was fine at least. And that’s all that matters. We forgot to mention one thing, I
think, and that is the winner of the race. Oh my god and I forgot his name. Ernesto Rivera?
Ernesto Rivera. He's a Red Bull junior at the Red Bull Ring. Tsolov is also a Red Bull junior, we also
didn't mention that. I think I know, they also want– they all want to win everywhere but I think
You’re Ernesto Rivera, and you win your first race at the Red Bull Ring, I think that's special.
Yeah that's really cool. And then again if you're Fionn and you… kind of crash people at the Red Bull
Ring. I mean he's just been struggling the whole season though nothing… this step up has just harmed
him a lot, going straight from British F4 to like– it’s very Tsolov-like what he's done because
of course, Tsolov went from Spanish F4 straight to F3, and he really struggled at the start. But I also
feel like Hitech is just not the best because first of all, Jin Nakamura is kind of- he's doing
good all things considered, but other than that Hitech is just not scoring points and it could
be the fact that their drivers, you know, just aren't ready for it. But I just also think–
I'm going to be honest– if he was in like Campos or Trident, he would definitely be doing better.
But we can't because, he has– of course, done a quite a big step up as well.
I mean he's even in, even Oceania, he did struggle quite a bit. I wouldn't say that he
would automatically be winning and stuff but I think that if he was in- maybe he'd get some
points at least. And another thing that I think is these are circuits that he just does not know
at all and like especially Monaco and Australia; they were two circuits he just had no experience
on. I mean at least, Silverstone, Silverstone would be the only one– Silverstone would be the only one
he knows on the whole calendar. Like I think we make a lot of fun of like drivers who you know
if a driver from Italian F4 would make the step, we would make fun but in the last – I know this
season we only have Italian circuits– but in the last few seasons, we've also oftentimes had other
circuits and I think it was it was Ollie Bearman who also skipped FREC right? Like I think he also
jumped from– but, but he went from Italian and German F4 he did both of those. Italian F4 and
German F4. I think both even two seasons so he knew the circuits they were like he knew definitely
Monza, Imola. I'm pretty sure that they've also did some rounds potentially in Austria or Belgium.
I'm not quite sure–and I don't want anyone to quote me on this–but also having the knowledge
of Italian circuits, the circuits like Austria is closer than British circuits are to Austria.
Yeah anyways, I think we should, um look at the feature race, where it was a really fun battle
for the win towards the end between Freddie, Ugo and Stromsted. I think Freddie kind of
cooked his tires towards the end but I think that's maybe partly true because they all are
the top ones in the podium, they all have a little bit of F3 experience, but he still had some quite
good defensive moves against– I think, he can just take a lot to learn, I mean, he was in the lead
I mean, I'm sad he didn't win. I think he could have won, he had the pace to do so, I think,
I think, just keeping the tires is so important this weekend, and I think he just
slightly let go of them towards the end. I think it's the same conversation as we have with F2
where we all kind of expected Freddie and Trident to just run away with the title, especially after
the performance shown in recent years, but it's pretty clear to me that–I'm going to be honest
and I'm going to say– I think Campos is overall the stronger car and stronger team. It's coming from
you and not from me, meaning if I say that, I'm obviously biased. Because you know, I feel like
I mean, in the team's championship, Trident isn't even second, they’re third, they're still behind
Van Amersfoort. Yeah because I mean de Palo's just been not doing anything, I think he's
also really struggling. Yeah, but also I expected also more from the duo of you know, Stromsted and
Slater like we expected quite a lot from. Apart from this weekend, Stromsted has actually not
been doing–if I take away this weekend's performance–he's not actually been performing that well- I mean
of course, he's won this weekend. Yeah that's why I'm trying to point out, going into 2025 we all
expected Stromsted to be–honestly, I didn't expect him to win like the championship, but I expected
him to be someone you would see on the podium quite a handful of times you know? He's one of
those drivers, I need to check before I say something wrong and I get cancelled again.
Like Formula Regional, he was with RPM and he still scored a pole and handful of podiums
and you know it's not that, he's like the greatest driver ever, but especially with a team like Trident
I expected him to be up there I expected him to do something
you know, but this far he has scored a handful of points, he's like p6 in the championship, I think he
was also up there last season but it's not what we've been expecting and it's definitely not
what should happen when you're in a team that scored, you know the last three championships
for a reason. Yeah but I mean, at least the championship, I mean Freddie still, I still
hope he can do something, you know one DNF for Ugo, Freddie gets some points but still not
too far apart. I mean, I'm still gonna believe in Freddie, of course I am, but I mean, he's, I mean he is
only 16 points behind Ugo, yeah it's not a massive gap. Simultaneously, Theophile Nael–who I
kind of have a soft spot for– is also only 10 points behind Freddie and we saw he had a bad
weekend but the season’s far from over, everything can still happen, a bad crash can still happen at
the wrong time and suddenly I think, I'll say that I think these three should probably make up the
championship. Bruno Del Pino is also only three points behind so I could also see him kind of
get in the mix, but he's not a driver that we've been seeing so much from but he's been very
consistent recently. Definitely, even looking at the teams Campos have nearly a 50 point lead in the
team's championship which is insane. Before we move on to the team's championship actually I
wanted to mention that this feature race was the first time this season that Del Pino didn't score
any points I'm pretty sure. Yeah I just wanted to point that out, because he is maybe not the one
who's like always winning and he won one race and had one further podium but he had a streak of
seven consecutive points finishes and that stuff that later can put you into the championship
uh position especially if like –I think we saw it at some point– where Ugochukwu crashed, I think it was
Spain, um where it was like please correct me if I'm wrong, but there was kind of like overtaking
stuff going on he was running pretty well and then crashed and it's like those things can cost you
very very valuable points and if you're someone who's consistently fighting for the win that's
more likely to happen than if you're someone who's in the points very comfortably, but –and
also obviously fighting but not quite up there for like really p1 aggressively–sometimes it's
good idea to take points home with you and you gain more because the guys in front of you
aren't happy enough and crash each other out. Yeah, he's been doing a really solid job, I think.
VAR, while they're not maybe as fast as Campos or Trident, they're still doing quite
solid, they are second in the team's championship but they– and they have been doing quite a solid
job I think with all three of their drivers they, they're still they're always getting solid
points they're always somewhere there in the points pretty much. Yeah, of course, VAR are only
six points ahead of VAR on the team's championship, but I think it's going to be Campos who wins this
I mean it's quite– You mean six points ahead of Trident? You said VAR is six points ahead of VAR.
No, other way, VAR is six points ahead of Trident within the standings but I think that's mainly
due to de Palo just not getting points for Trident. I think, Trident are maybe slightly-
It varies week to week it's like last time out in Spain, Trident were awful and VAR are really good
so maybe that this wins between them for who be second fastest I think we'll have a good fight
for second in the team's championship, I think first is probably- unless something like really dramatic
happens– I think first is pretty locked in. They get disqualified or- That happened to a team in GB4
actually one of the GB4 teams got disqualified from the entire championship! There’s precedent for it.
But yeah, unless something like majorly dramatic happens I think our fight that we should be
looking out for is for P2 in the team standings. Does anyone have anything to say about F3?
No, it was kind of boring. So the E4 season starts this weekend and it's been a very long time
since we've done a season preview because everything has already started like ages ago
but E4 is… it's not really a new championship, it's just a bit of a side championship to Italian F4
after ADAC F4 folded. A D A C. Okay whatever, okay ADAC F4 folded– We have to bring the German stuff.
Okay um, and it started in 2023 so it's not really it's kind of new so we've had only three
champions obviously, uh Ugo Ugochukwu won the first one, uh Akshay Bohra won in 2024 and KNB won in 2025
Akshay, come back we miss you. KNB was the first driver to win both Italian F4 and E4 in
the same year so we'll see if another driver can do the same thing or not, but like I said E4 is
very new so. It's incredibly similar to Italian F4, in terms of the grid. A few minor differences
but it's basically Italian F4 2.0. Yeah, so Prema lineup, they have seven cars again– Um wait, I have
a question, I have a question: do we get points for the top 15 or top 10? I don't know if they've
changed it for E4 or not actually. They changed it for Italian but I don't know if they changed it
for E4. I hope they also do the 15 points, because otherwise. I mean the grid is only 36 cars this time
I imagine they would because they're both run by ACI, aren't they? Yeah but yeah so
Prema lineup is the same seven cars as Italian F4 except Cosma has been replaced by
Georgiy Zasov? I don't know if I said that right but I'm a little bit surprised that Cosma's not
there just kind of because Aksoy had a bad weekend last time but he's the highest
Prema in the standings so to not see him there. It reminds me a bit of um R-ace last year where
Olivieri was doing Italian F4, but just didn't show up for Euro 4 or E4. E4, it was Euro 4 and then it
got changed to E4 last year. But I think it makes kind of sense but yeah. Because you have to keep
in mind the f***ing money that running all these championships cost, and I can imagine that if
you want to focus on Italian F4, you probably are getting you know out- outbidded if that’s
even a word, by other folks who you know want to drive but maybe only turned 15 recently or
don't feel like doing a whole season or you know, I can imagine and I can understand why someone
wouldn't do both. I think it's not doing both, I think it's purely maybe down to funding honestly,
that's as it always is in racing. Yeah but like imagine you ask your team but you're also doing
Italian F4 and you're like “hey, how about E4” and they're like “no, this guy has a lot more money and
he just does not usually care for Italian F4” and I feel like Italian- I feel like E4 is also one of
those things where we see more guys from other championships, you know, try out a bit of experience
on the Italian circuits. We'll get to that in a second because there is a couple drivers.
So, US Racing has the exact same lineup as they do for Italian F4 so Sammalisto, Savinkov, Killion,
Bansal, Busso, and- who am I missing? Um, Kräling, I'm missing a driver. Bansal? I said Bansal.
She said Bansal, Kräling. Just say Bansal twice. Speaking of Bansal, um. I'm go- okay I'm going
to issue an apology, I'm going to because I made a mistake, and I'm very very sorry for this and I
actually, they don't know but I actually have to do two apologies because one is really old but I still
feel bad about it and I have nightmares about it. The first apology is I said that Ary Bansal, uh, I said
something along the lines of uh, “he's kind of rookie because he only did GB4” which was wrong
you see, he also did British F4 and some other stuff, I think he did E4 last season no? I think so yeah.
The thing is, the embarrassing part of that is actually that I saw him race live in British F4 so I
don't know how the f**k I forgot that I saw him, and I'm pretty sure I even saw him score- win, I'm
fairly sure about that. I don't know how the f**k I missed that, but I am pretty sure that I must
have mixed him up with someone else. And when I think of Ary Bansal, I do not think of British
F4, I think of GB4, because that was the season he won the championship which was really cool
and a second one, and I'm really still embarrassed about this because you'll need to shoot me for
this, is that very very early in the season, when we were talking about F1 Academy, I said that Tina
Hausmann did not do other things, but that's also wrong because she did do, uh, I think it was Italian
F4 and E4 at some point, and she didn't even do it too badly. And I’m really embarrassed about it because
I- I need to shoot myself because, I always say that I have everything in mind about drivers
but for some reason I forgot that and I must have also mixed it up with someone else.
And I'm so embarrassed I'm going to retire. Um I just remembered which driver I forgot in the
US Racing lineup, I forgot Robinson. We are going to get murdered by the Spanish fans.
But yeah so, R-ace GP, their lineup from Italian F4, we have Andy, Kenzo and Tamás, but um.
We- I don't know where Emily is, she's not here, and so, the fourth and fifth cars are
going to the Karras brothers from Spanish F4. I cannot lie to you, I don't know how they're
doing in Spanish F4. E4 kind of feels like a filler episode in an anime. I've- from the announcements
that R-ace made, Payton Westcott should be doing one round of E4, but I don't know how
we're going to be doing that. Do we have a sixth car for her, is she going to take the place of one
of the other drivers? I mean we saw it in other seasons where you know, drivers would miss one
race and I don't know- has anyone checked if Spanish F4 overlaps with E4? I have not checked
actually. Because I can imagine that being a thing. As far as I know Emily's not doing
anything in E4 this year, like she's not competing in it at all, which is kind of sad. And I wonder if
it's money or- or in which direction it is maybe money, because either it's she cannot afford it
and she's saying hey maybe- or she can afford it, but maybe she's saying she wants to take the money
for else things like testing or doing other stuff. Or, what I could also imagine the Karras brothers
because I also don't know them, maybe they've got a lot of money and if you only have a limited
number of cars and they say “hey, we're paying more than she does.” I think they do have a lot of money,
I just don't know how much a lot of money is. I mean if you have two children and they’re brothers
and, you know you're the parent and you can fund both their racing careers, you gotta have a bit of money.
Yeah. Uh, to answer the Spanish F4 questions, the Karras brothers are not doing very well.
Um, they've only scored points twice each, and yeah there is a round that, um, coincides from
SF4 and it's the Monza round. Maybe they just really like the Italian circuits. So, would they
I- would they um prioritize E4 or Spanish F4 do you think? Cause like if they're not doing very
well in Spanish F4, and they want to gain experience elsewhere, I could see them
prioritizing going to Monza instead, but who knows. I could see that but I also would think
Spanish F4 is the longer running championship that they're doing but we'll see. I mean if you want to
track who sponsors what are you going to say, “hey maybe I didn't have the best season, but
you know I raced all-” I think it's seven or eight rounds or something like that.
you know, “I improved” or do you say “hey, in this championship where I have nine races in general”
I think if you want to use E4 to advertise yourself, you have to do really good.
And if I was a driver I would not risk that. What team do they race for in Spanish F4? I have absolutely
no idea. G4. Uh, so not a very good team. R-ace is quite a good team, so I could see them doing
at least better than they are in Spanish F4. But also, you have to imagine the possibility if you go in
you do really well, and then instead of returning for a second weekend, you just leave and you say
“hey I could have done even more, but I didn't want to” even if you couldn't have done better.
Just like a bit of stat padding, you know. Um, so that's the first cameo from drivers in other
championships. We also have George Proudford-Nalder in again with AKM. I hope he can have a better time
out. Yeah um, for him and also luckily for Andy Consani, is that because the grid is 36 cars,
there is no fourth race so there is no possibility for either of them to
not qualify for the third- for their third race. You say that now just for them to DNS.
Oh. Whatever happens, it's better than a DNQ, okay. You're saying this now but
are we sure that they can't DNQ. I mean- yeah there’s only three races. Yeah but what I'm saying
is, if they don't show that they can qualify and just all their laps are below the, I mean I assume
in Italian F4 there's another rule. I think if this happens, if that somehow happens, I think Robin
will actually come for you. Just gonna show up at your house. I don't bring bad luck, I just bring good luck. Um, so anyways, a lot of
the teams have the same lineups that they do for Italian F4. So VAR, PHM, Trident, Cram and Real Racing
all have their same lineups. Basically Italian F4 2.0.
AKM, like I mentioned they have George Proudford-Nalder, and they also have Orsini, they've um-
So they've cut down their lineup from four drivers to two. These drivers just sound like uh, noodle
types. Um, I don't know how to say this team's name or their driver's name, and I don't really
feel like getting cancelled. No we gotta try because I was- I was bullied last week for not trying.
I did not bully you last week, that had nothing to do with me. The thing is it's either Scuderia
Buell or it's Scuderia Bull but someone can't spell. I was thinking Buell, but I don't think
that's right either. it could also be Buell but that also sounds stupid as f**k. And I think
the name is Joaquin Rubino, or is there another way to pronounce that? I was thinking Joaquin
Rubino. I always thought if you pronounce names it's just like you know we said it once, everyone
who is a big fan of him should guess what I'm trying to say. If anyone can teach us how to
pronounce either of the team name or the driver's name, please let us let us know. I think we should
do that for- for one episode in the summer break where nothing races, and we just try to pronounce
every single name. But yeah, so um I don't know anything about this team,
um, I don't think they were there for E4 last year, um, so we'll see how that goes.
Out of the relevant teams from Italian F4, both Jenzer and Maffi Racing are missing.
I expected them to be there but like at the same time, I'm not surprised that they're not there.
Jenzer had quite a big, um, you know, group last year. Or not big, because they only had two who
did the whole thing, and then quite a handful of drivers who did the first and the third round.
Uh, so I think Jenzer and Maffi are both, especially Jenzer, more in Central European Zone F4,
so I could imagine if they, you know, have their attention there that they're going to like,
it's a waste of time also going into E4. Yeah maybe. So I think that's all for teams and
lineups, in terms of the calendar we have Vallelunga this weekend, um Paul Ricard from
July 17th to 19th, and then Monza as a finale October 9th to 11th. Like I mentioned
earlier, 36 cars means it's not the four race format, we just have the normal three race format,
where we have two qualifying sessions, quali 1 determines the grid for race 1, quali 2
for race 2, and then race 3 is a driver's second best time from either session, so if you
set your second best time in quali 1, that's what they'll use, if you set your best time in
quali 2, then that's what they'll use, it's depending on where you set your second best time.
I think we need to talk about a big problem here, which is personal to me because there's
not a single woman in for Vallelunga. And there's a few explanations for that, but I'm still
not happy with that. We obviously have uh no F1 Academy drivers, because Silverstone
is on at the same time, and they have to prioritize that, but we are also missing Emily Cotty and
Ginevra Panzeri, and for Panzeri I think she's actually actively avoiding doing it, because
Vallelunga is irrelevant, she could do Vallelunga, but Paul Ricard is also driven as the French F4
final, we know French F4 is super weird about these things, and I could totally imagine them saying
that she's not allowed to do a race on Paul Ricard before French F4 goes to Paul Ricard.
And Monza is the same weekend as Paul Ricard in French F4, and since she has to prioritize
French F4, she could only do Vallelunga which would be a lot of money, for what exactly?
But I don't know why we are not seeing Emily Cotty, if we look at the last- I’m so sad about it. If we llok few years we usually saw
a handful of female drivers and I'm surprised and I'm going to say something crazy- I'm surprised
we're not seeing Aurelia Nobles return, because she did it in both ‘24 and ‘25 and ‘23 actually, she
did it in Austin, and she's doing GB3 at the moment so it could be that there's an overlap there, but
I've always had a feeling that she really likes driving in Italy so. I mean yeah for this weekend
for example, GB3 is already on so that's- but I could totally see that we get female drivers
in the next few weekends because, if I look back at 2025 like Matilda Paatz, I expect to see, because
I just have- I just have it in feeling that she's kind of- she- I feel like, she did it definitely
last season but I- didn't she also do Italian F4, but like I also think that she had interest to
be there and furthermore obviously with having Matilda Racing behind her, I could imagine
them kind of entering, or she is- is AS Motorsport doing it this season?
No, they're not currently on the grid, but we could see them do a one-off entry at some point.
Yeah, I kind of hope that we see Matilda do that, especially if we have the points up to 15th again.
We’ll have to look into that, because I have no idea we'll find out over the weekend if it's
top 10 or top 15. I think we should- I still think we should do it like IndyCar and just
give everyone points. So, do we want to discuss predictions? I mean, I think we've learnt. I mean
I'm just going to say it, US Racing teams championship, the dominance continues. But it's
not going to be Sammalisto who comes on top, it's going to be some random guy- I'm going to go
Robinson. I'm not making the same mistake that I did for Italian F4. That’s why I'm saying Robinson
champion because who knows for this championship. Because um Bondarev has underwhelmed me and
Consani is incredibly unlucky, so I'm not predicting either of them to be in the title fight.
I'm going to say- this is really really boring but I don't want to embarrass myself again.
So US Racing teams champions, I said this in Italian F4 by the way so that's like,
the one thing I got right. You said that in a non-serious manner. Okay but still whatever.
Um, and then for driver's champion I'm going to be boring, and say Sammalisto, just because he's
absolutely dominated Italian F4 and like Vallelunga is a repeat from Italian F4, same with
Monza. I love Monza. Fork found in kitchen. I think- and I'm going to- I'm going to absolutely agree I
think we're going to see US Racing win the teams championship, but I'm also going to be biased
I'm going to be called a fake fan, I'm going to say Ary Bansal wins the championship and- but it's
close with Alp Aksoy, because I think he's also been doing really, really well, and I'm really
sure Alp Aksoy is winning the rookie championship, I think that should be a good guess. I'm just scared
to predict anything, every time we have it's gone down the drain, so yeah sure US Racing.
championship, whatever. So is there anything left to say? Um, not really, I hope everyone enjoyed this
week's episode of our podcast. As always, let us know your thoughts and we'd love to hear your
predictions for Italian- I mean for Euro 4. Do you think the US Racing dominance is going to
continue, or are we going to see Prema come back or maybe R-ace? Join us next week where we're
going to cover F2, F3 and F1 Academy at Silverstone, of course Euro 4 at Vallelunga,
FREC at the Hungaroring, and EC3 at Imola. It's gonna be a long episode with
six series to cover, so hope you guys enjoy it. Next episode is going to be
three hours long probably, if we have to talk about everything. And it's going to be an hour
of just me crashing out. And another hour of just me raving about Alisa Palmovsky's perfect performance.